.
I think we have reviewed the quadratic formula well
But if you do not remember her yet, let me
Write it down again
Let's assume that we have a quadratic equation
In the form of ax ^ 2 + bx + c = 0
Quadratic formula, which we have shown in the last presentation
The solution to this equation is x =
-b + or - square root of b ^ 2
- 4ac, all divided by 2a
Now in this view, instead of giving you a set of
Examples of compensation in a, b, and c
I want to talk about this part of
Quadratic formula, this part is there
Ie b ^ 2-4ac
We have seen it in a range of issues that we have resolved
As examples, as it is considered determinants
Of the form in which the solution appears
For example, if b ^ 2 - 4ac is greater than 0
We'll get two solutions, will not we?
The square root of a positive number is
Non-zero, the image will be positive and negative
Of it - we will always get b / 2a or
-b / 2a - then you will get -b +
Positive square root, and -b-
The square root is positive, all divided by 2a
If the differentiation is greater than 0, therefore
We will have two solutions
I now use the word, a differentiation
All this goes back to this part of
Quadratic formula
This - let me do this in another color - this
Is the differentiation of the quadratic equation
Here
Differentiation
And you have to remember, it's the part that falls under
The root symbol of the quadratic formula
That's why we care about it, because if it's bigger
From 0, we get a positive square root, and
We get his positive and negative image, will
You get two solutions
Now, what happens if b ^ 2 - 4ac = 0?
If this equals 0 - if you take b ^ 2 - 4, ×
a × c, this equals 0 - this tells us that this
The portion of the quadratic formula will be 0, and
The square root of 0 is 0
Then the only solution would be x
= -b / 2a
Or another way is that
You have only one solution
If the differentiation is 0
You only have one solution
You have only one solution
So the solution would be the head, or
X coordinate for the head, because it will get
A parabola touches the x-axis so, just touches it
Here, or so touching him, touches him in
One point, when b ^ 2 - 4ac = 0
Hence the latter case is if b ^ 2-4ac
Less than 0
b ^ 2 - 4ac less than 0
Then here, you will get a negative number under
Root
We have seen an example of this in the last presentation
If we are dealing with real numbers, we can not take
A square root for a negative number, that is to say
There are no real solutions
In the future, we will see that we will get complex solutions
But if we are dealing with real numbers
We will not have a real solution
Because this is illogical
The square root of a negative number, at least this is not
Logical for real numbers
Then there's a lot to think about
If we have positive differentiation, ie if b ^ 2
- 4ac positive, we can think about whether
Solutions are relative or not
If this is 2, then we will get a squared root for 2
In the answer, the answer will be non-relative, or
The answers will be relatively irrelevant
If b ^ 2 - 4ac = 16, we know that this square is full
We take the square root of the whole square
We get a relative answer
However, with all this, let's solve some examples
Because I think that's what it will all make
These ideas are concrete
Suppose I have the equation xx ^ 2
+ 3x - 6 = 0
All I want to do is to know a little
The type of solutions you own
I do not want to find the value of x
If I encounter such a situation, I can only see it
Differentiation
I can see b ^ 2-4ac
What is the difference here? b ^ 2 = 9-4
× a -i -1-- × c, ie -6
How much is this?
This negative sign and negative sign are deleted, however
We still have that negative signal there, if it equals 9
- 4, x 6
This is equal to 9 - 24, ie less than
If we get a smaller number of 0 under
Root
If we do not get a real solution
This is intended
So this chart will be going down, because
He has a negative signal there, so it seems
So
If this axis is x, the graph will be curved down
His head will be down the x-axis and open down, so
It will never intersect with the X axis
We have no real solutions
Let us solve another example
Let's say I have - I'll solve it with pink - let's say
I have the equation, 5x ^ 2 = 6x
Well, let's put it in the picture we used to
So let's subtract 6x from both ends, and get 5x ^ 2
- 6x = 0
Let's count the differentiation
Want to get b ^ 2
b ^ 2 = -6 ^ 2 - 4
× a × c
Well, where is c here?
There is no c here
There is + 0 and I have not written it here
No c
In this case, c = 0
There is no c in this equation
If x 0
So delete all of it
6 ^ 2 = positive 36
The differentiation is positive
We have a value of 36 under the root code here, if
It is not only positive, but also a whole square
This shows that I will get two solutions
I will get two real solutions
They will not only be real, but I also know
They will be relative, because I have
Square root of 36
The square root for 36 is + or - 6
I will not end up with a disproportionate number here
Two real solutions are also relative
They are also relative
This is the case we have here
You can also get a non-relative solution here
and this is
+ Non-proportional solution
Let us solve it further, so that we can understand the idea
Let's assume that I have 41x ^ 2 - 31x
- 52 = 0
Again, I want to think about the type
The solution I will probably deal with
b ^ 2 - 4ac
b ^ 2
-31 ^ 2 - 4, × a, × x 41, ×
c - x x - 52
What do I have here?
This is equal to 31 ^ 2 positive
Negative × negative
= Positive
I'll get a positive, will not I?
This is equivalent to 31 ^ 2, + - this
Positive number here, I mean, we can calculate it
But it is 4 × 41 × 52
All I will care for is positive differentiation
It's bigger than 0, so that means that
I have two real solutions
We can think about whether this will be
A complete plague
I do not know
I will not do this here
Because it will require a large account space
We know that they are real, and we do not know if they are relative solutions
Or non-relative
Let us solve another example
Let's assume that I have x ^ 2 - 8x
+ 1 = 0
Again, let's look at the differentiation
b ^ 2, so-8 ^ 2 - 4, × a
Ie 1, x c, ie 16
This equals 64 - 64, equal to 0
If we have only one solution, according to the definition will
Be relatively
I mean, we can look at him here
He (x - 4) (x - 4) = 0
The only solution is x = 4
And when I say according to the definition of the square formula
Look here, if this is 0, all that will remain is
-b / 2a, which is no doubt will be
Relative, assuming you have a, b, and c, of course
Are relative numbers
Anyway, I hope you found this useful
It's a quick way
It does not require you to find a solution
But you just have to say what types of solutions or how much
Number of solutions, how many real solutions, or predict whether
Are real or relative solutions
Differentiation can be a useful shortcut
Well I think it made you appreciate the importance of parts
The quadratic formula is better
.